Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by convert
kit. My go to email service provider.
I use them for everything. If you've
ever wondered how professional bloggers,
podcasters,
youtubers and so on can build a platform
they control and get the word out about
their best content. Email is still the
answer. People think it's all social,
social, social, but one algorithm
change and oops, bait and switch.
Now you only reach 10% of your audience.
That is why I've doubled
and tripled down on email.
After reviewing many different
email service providers,
I ended up selecting convert kit
for email like five bullet Friday,
which goes out to about a million people
now because convert kit delivers on
what matters most to me at
least easy to use. Systems,
split testing and resending
technology, both very, very important.
High rates of deliverability and
great hands on customer service.
So whether you run a
business or simply have,
say a serious blog convert kit has
integrations with more than 70 different
services just about anything you might
need including hosting sites like
wordpress,
ecommerce platforms like Shopify,
lead capture technology like bounce
exchange or sumo and many more.
They also offer a visual
automation builder that makes
it really easy to deliver
the right content to the right people
in your audience just when they want it.
If you want a segment in different ways,
which a lot of people do,
convert kit offers, plans that
adjusted the size of your business,
so it's a good option whether you have
a thousand people or 1 million on your
list.
And certainly I am planning on growing
and growing and growing and I don't like
switching email service providers,
so I thought very carefully about this
before I selected them. So check it out.
Take a look@convertkit.com forward
slash Tim that's convert Con v,
e r t k,
I t.com forward slash Tim and you can
get your first month for free to kick the
tires, test it out. That
way you can give it a shot.
Make sure that it works for you, your
business and all of that. Goodness.
If you're like me, I hope you'll
find that they get the job done.
That's certainly been my
experience, so check it out. Again,
that's convert kit.com forward slash
Tim for a free month of email services.
This episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for
blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for
everything every day. My site,
tim.blog is built on it. The websites
for my books, including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors. It's all
on wordpress.com and the
founder Matt Mullenweg.
One of my close friends has
appeared on the show many times.
Just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site, or both,
you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be
in good company. It's used
by the New Yorker, Jay Z,
Beyonce, five 38 tech crunch, Ted, CNN,
and time just to name a handful,
and one
of my
friends@googlewhoshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers the best out of the
box SEO imaginable and quote,
and it's one of the many reasons that
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you
through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of
designs and templates that
you can use and it's easy to
get started. There's no need to
worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that there for 24
seven support, and they're very,
very responsive. If you have
questions, they get right back to you.
And this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction. So if
you're building a website, period,
when my friends come to me and ask
what I use, what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com
so check it out.
If you want to get started today,
learn more with a 15%
discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim
to create your website and find the plan
that's right for you. So
learn more. Take a look.
wordpress.com four slashed him
for 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
End My brand new podcast tribe of mentors
because this guest is suitable for
both Mike Maples. He's one of my favorite
people, one of my oldest mentors,
not in biological age,
but he goes back probably 1520 years
teaching me and he is the man who
effectively taught me how to invest
and the audio you're going to hear was
recorded in front of a sold out audience
at the Castro theatre in San Francisco.
It was a blast.
Thank you everyone for coming out and
it takes us a few minutes to warm up and
then we get into not only investing
but also his life philosophies,
parenting. He is such a splendid
human being and has a very,
very wide set of skills.
So I hope you enjoy this
conversation with Mike Maples.
Yeah,
thank you so much for coming everybody.
This is going to be great
and I'll read some suggested
introductory remarks. First,
thank you all for coming tonight.
Welcome to tonight's program with
Inforum at the Commonwealth club.
And what I'm not going to do is sit here
and regurgitate stuff that is already
in the book that you just
bought cause that's very boring.
So what I thought I would do instead is
invite one of my friends who is in this
book to join me on stage and to
dig into some of the old stories,
the stuff you guys haven't heard and to
really just banter because he is one of
my favorite people.
So who is this favorite person?
Kevin Rose is one of my favorite people
but he has a brand new human being to
take care of. So he is not here to boost
it up with Ferris. I'm very sad to say
Mike maples junior can find them on
twitter@mtwojrfloodgate.com Mike maples
junior is a partner at floodgate of
venture capital firm that specializes in
microcap investments in startups.
He's also the person
responsible for introducing me
to tech investing in general
and we go way,
way back.
He has been on the Forbes Midas list
since 2010 and named one a fortune
magazine's eight rising stars before
becoming a full time investor.
This is very important.
Mike was an operator.
He was involved as a founder and
operating executive at back to back.
Startup IPO is including Tivoli systems.
It's acquired by IBM motive IPO
motive acquired by Alcatel Lucent.
Some of Mike's investments include
Twitter, twitch dot. TV, Ng, Moco, Weebly,
check Bizaarvoice Spiceworks, Okta demand
for us and many, many, many others.
Please help me welcome to
the stage Mike Maples, right?
Yeah.
Thought we were just having a little
chat at like a bookstore or something.
I guess you tend to draw a crowd.
I keep forgetting that still. Yeah,
I was trying to
put us connecting on a timeline
and I think we've had a number of,
of interactions beginning
it had to be back pre 2000.
I think it, and I think when we
first started catching up, it was um,
the right before you had done the
four hour workweek and you were so,
um, Tim, Tim wasn't sure what to call
this, but am I just anything goes,
anything goes, I may regret. But
yeah, so, so Tim and you know,
I'm a little bit less over my
skis sometimes and Tim is, uh,
well it depends on the area
but w whatever. So, um,
but so Tim was deciding
whether to call the book, uh,
the four hour workweek or drug
dealing for fun and profit. And,
um, and I was like, Tim, why do you want
to write a book about being a Druggie?
You know, this is just terrible
idea. You know, you'd be,
it's just a terrible influence, just,
just a bad idea. And Tim was like, well,
you know, you really want
to get people, you know,
sort of provoked the point of departure,
right to, to get access to the ideas.
And so we did this thing, I think we
called it ghetto testing where we said,
hey look, let's not argue, let's
not in your opinion versus mine.
Let's just test the two
titles and just say, Hey,
by the four hour workweek, hey, by
drug dealing for fun and profit.
And you know, neither book exists yet.
So people would click on it and they get
a four o four error.
But we could,
we could understand like
what got the better response.
And so now it was no longer your
opinion versus mine. It was just like,
what do people respond to?
So we did this.
That's my recollection. No, we had this
testing, but it goes even further back.
So you had appeared,
I was more of a spectator in a
class that I took in college,
like undergraduate back when
I had more hair on my head.
And Mike came to talk
about thunder lizards. Yes.
Which we'll talk about in a moment.
And that was part of what piqued
my interest in silicon valley,
the bay area,
the excitement,
certainly at the time 99 who granted
I was an exciting time to be running
towards the precipice also.
Uh, but got me out here.
And then our conversations around the
time that the four hour work week came
out, uh, involved to my recollection,
many things. But we would sit at,
and I might be getting this
wrong, but hobbies, hobbies, yeah.
In town and country town,
which unfortunately no longer with us.
Have it on at Raster Darrow.
And we used to just eat omelets and uh,
and talk about marketing and PR,
but also about the deals that you
were becoming involved with. Yeah.
And the, the testing for people
who don't know, it was very simple.
I mean we had a number of different
titles and a used Google ad words,
which was, I mean it was the
golden age of Google ad words.
You could just shoot fish in a barrel. It
was so inexpensive. And so he took the,
the headlines prospective
headlines as the,
as the actual ad headlines and then the
perspective subtitles as the ad text and
then had all these unique URLs that,
like you said,
and went nowhere because all we really
cared about was the click through rate.
What I also did, if we want to talk
about businesses going out of business,
there are a lot of them to point to is
I went to Palo Alto University AV to the
borders that existed at the
time and to test covers.
I had mock ups that I printed out and I
would wrap a book that was roughly the
same size.
I thought mine would be put it up during
what I perceived to be rush hour at
borders.
Not sure how I figured that out.
And I would say stand there like a
bouncer, keeping track of fire code,
like click,
click watching the number of people
who picked it up like every 15 minutes.
So I get, try to look at the
visual appeal of different covers.
Now it's a lot easier. You don't have
to quite do that. It's still this wine.
Oh yeah, I should, maybe I need some
booze up here and we'll get to that.
Uh,
but what I wanted to do,
so can I just interject one other thing
about these books should interject with
any other things.
So I went to Kepler's
bookstore and printers ink,
I guess, right, because they're,
they're like well known as
bellwether bookstores and, uh,
and I was like, I'm going to, I went
and bought $1,000 worth of his book,
four hour work week at both bookstores.
And we didn't really know at the time,
but bellwether bookstores
kind of trigger supply chains.
And so it's a little bit like before
the APP store happened, right.
Cause the iPhone out yet.
And so, so like I'd go into
these bookstores and I'd be like,
how many copies do you
have in the bookstore?
I want to buy him all because this
book's going to be hot and I'm doing this
offsite and I need every copy you've got.
Cause I doubt you have enough copies
for all people in this organization.
I've run. And so it was just
me at the time. But, uh,
but like what it turned out it was true,
right? It like, it becomes, oh wow.
Kepler's bookstore in printer's ink.
They're selling out like crazy as four
hour work week and that is the hot heat
seeker on the New York Times. And then
more people read it too because up in the,
and obviously it was a good book
that helped, but uh, but it was like,
just looking back on it,
how, how crazy that was.
Cause I that like maybe you thought
it was gonna be this huge, uh,
breakout bestseller, but I
remember I was just like, Hey,
I'll read these drafts blank however
I can. And like, I hope it works out.
But yeah,
whatever it was.
I think you offered one of the very
first blurbs in the first edition of four
hour workweek. Halftone read additional
copies. I go, okay, yeah. You're like,
I ended up doing a quote too.
She was like, okay, I'll do one.
But when we're talking about
this alchemy for instance,
Kepler's let's just say,
unbeknownst to me,
there's certain stores that trigger
certain other things and there's this
Mexican black magic, but there's
this, uh, these tipping points.
So now people look at what
you've accomplished and
the investments you've made
and the minus list and everything. And
it's, Oh my God, Mike maples sort of in,
in quotation marks. But my
understanding is that, uh,
you had a tough time getting hired as
a venture capitalist when you first got
here. Talk a little bit about that. You
know, it's like in a coach bill camp.
How many people have heard of Coachville
Campbell before a fair number? Uh,
and for those of you haven't,
I'll just give the quick version.
Bill was an early executive at apple and
then he ran a company called Claris and
then go, which flamed out.
And then he was CEO of intuit,
but probably more significantly became
kind of the most famous coach in Silicon
Valley. He had been a football
coach before. He's a business guy.
And so he was on the board of Google and
apple and a actually I got a chance to
work with him and Twitter
and in a demand force,
which for two companies he got involved
with that we invested in. And um, uh,
Bill's favorite song was you can't
always get what you want by the rolling
stones. And, uh, it always
struck me that, and I,
we won't do too much of
the book, but um, that,
that sometimes you use the stuff you're
not getting right now that you think you
want wasn't the thing you really wanted.
And so I couldn't get any venture firms
to hire me coming to silicon valley.
I was just this random guy who'd moved
to Silicon Valley from Austin, Texas.
Never done an angel investment in my
life. And uh, you know, Kevin Rose,
one of your favorite guys.
One of my favorites too.
I'm the first to bat entrepreneurs
I ever backed were Evan Williams,
uh, who ended up doing Twitter
and then Kevin Rose. And uh,
by the time I met Kevin,
no venture firm would hire me.
Nobody thought I knew consumer Internet
cause I was an enterprise software guy.
Nobody thought I knew how to invest.
And I was like, Kevin, look, I just, um,
I really need you to take my money
on this thing. And I, you know,
that's what we call a leverage open trade.
I'm afraid that I'm,
I'm going to have to go on hunger strike
in your apartment if you don't take my
money in this dig deal.
And, um, you know, he,
he ended up letting,
letting me, you know, uh,
Kevin and then Jay Adelson let me
invest and dig and uh, you know,
dig had a kind of a circuitous path,
but, um, you know, I look back on it.
Um,
that was the sort of the booster rocket.
Yeah. And uh, you know, it's funny.
People talk about who back to
them or whatever. Um, you know,
I think that it, it was, uh,
Kevin's generosity that, uh,
sorta sorta got people I'd, sorry, get,
no, I get caught up with this stuff.
Sorry about that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so you and I share a similar
affection for the same guy. Yeah.
Kevin's a sweetheart of a guy. Yeah. Also,
one goofy motherfucker is you guys know
I, well, you know more about this stuff.
I know more about, well,
we won't get into that,
but how do you connect with Kevin? I mean,
how did that meeting end up happening?
Well, it was a, Ron Conway
was really generous. So, um,
I heard about this guy named Ron Conway.
I reached out to him who,
I mean probably still, but it was
thought of as the godfather of fame,
the most famous angel investor
of the world. Right. And so,
so we go to the oasis and,
and uh, was it the oasis?
I care maybe the goose and uh, I
say, well, you're wrong. No, no.
A restaurant in Palo Alto
and Menlo Park knows,
I think it was the goose.
And, um, and, and so, so, uh,
so w Ron's like, hey, great
to meet you. And I said, Ron,
I just want one chance, just one
chance to work with you on one thing.
Just give me one chance. It's all I
need. And he's like, okay, whatever.
You get your chance. What does
that mean? And I said, well,
there's this company that
I'm interested in called dig.
Then I had to come up with my
own independent conviction about,
but there's no way, like, how am I gonna
ever get in touch with Kevin Rose? Right?
I'm just some random dude.
It's so, uh, so Ron's like,
he looks at his spreadsheet and he's like,
Oh yeah,
I'm meeting with him next week. You want
to come with me to see dig? And I'm like,
sure, let's do it. And I
just knew there be, you know,
I knew what they were trying to do.
You know,
I cared a lot about their
mission and you know,
I wasn't talking about things
like cohort analysis or you know,
well like what was the retention
and the decay factor of the users.
It was more like,
you guys are transforming journalism
and this is like super important.
And it's like the wisdom
of the crowds to stories.
And it's so like it was just,
I think that part of why Kevin gave me
a shot and Jay was that they just knew I
just cared a lot about what they're
doing for my own reasons. Well,
I think that from,
from the opposite side of
the hubbies brunch table,
when I heard you talking about startups,
you are always genuinely personally
vested and excited about the products and
you spent a lot of time not just looking
at the deal structure and the this and
the that and the particulars of
whatever the projections might be.
But the product itself and
knowing Kevin as well as I do now,
like I would see that as a key factor.
I mean also many other things to him
then gravitating to you in that way.
And I, when I think back
to our, our lunches,
we've talked about all these various
things and I would pepper Mike with all
these questions like, wait, what's,
what's a claw back? What's a Pro Rad?
I don't know what that is.
What's this, what's that?
And eventually like any of it matters.
It's,
it's all blindfolded
monkeys throwing darts.
But I really wanted to know how the best
blindfolded monkeys through the darts.
So we're digging into it.
And I remember at the time I was,
I was pretty brief.
This was before the four hour work week
popped because keep in mind that that
book had initial initial print run in
between 10 and 12,000 copies, right?
I mean not even national distribution,
no one expected it to do
really much of anything.
And I was eager to take a little vacation
and I thought this two year vacation
called an Mba might be interesting.
So I was looking at Stanford business
school and I made all these visits and
there was some great classes.
One was taught by Pete Wendell,
a venture capital inside the trenches,
really great class by an operator.
But then there's all this theoretical
stuff that I just couldn't quite stomach.
And after, I don't know, four or five
of these lunches, I said, wait a second,
maybe I could put together a real
world MBA and make this, you know,
Tim Ferriss Fund in principle and spent
120 grand over two years and learn all
these things.
And develop all these relationships
and view the 120 k's sunk costs,
like that's gone. It's tuition,
but I don't know if you recall,
but right off the bat,
what do I do?
So I asked Mike if he'd be
willing to let me piggyback on,
on a couple of deals to co-invest and be
really a sort of cheap labor to try to
over deliver to these companies. And
uh, if you want to mention it, you can,
but I'm not going to bring up the name of
the company, but they're, this company,
uh, that, uh, you, you, you were
very measured in, in assessing.
And he told me about it and it was super
popular I think in Taiwan or somewhere
and I got so over enthused.
I was like,
I want to put in 50 k now keep in mind
that's like 50 k of 60 for my first year.
And in the first deal I want to do 59.
I remember you said to me at the time,
and you're very Mike way,
you said, well, well Tim, uh,
don't you think that might be a little
aggressive? And I was like, no man,
this is going to be the next Google. And
then I just saw your like, okay. And then,
uh, yeah, that didn't, that didn't,
uh, that, that forced me though.
If you want to talk about like life
saving you from what you want losing,
I mean it wasn't immediately lost.
That's part of the tricky one
tricky aspect of the startup stuff.
It's like you might not have a clean
loss for many, many, many years.
I just might have like you
solve that quickly. Yeah.
So you might have a walking dead
scenario where it's just like,
I am legend and you're
like, oh, now what do I do?
Kind of like certain areas in
SF past six o'clock anyway, so
I need more alcohol so I can excuse all
the things that I'm going to say. Uh,
where was I? Oh yes. So the,
the point was I had to then figure out
something called advising because I was
already out of money in year one.
And that led to in that period of time,
a lot of the absolute best connections
that I made, including just to,
just to highlight something that comes
up over and over again in tribe of
mentors. It comes up over and over
again in conversations with you.
There are these catastrophes or business
failures that really end up in no
uncertain terms, sowing the seeds
of really huge leader success.
Right? Like you mentioned
the Securitas path of dig,
but who cares because you befriended and
became an ally of Kevin Rose who knows
everyone just about in tech and is very
generous with making introductions and
if he cares about you and believes in you,
he'll make those introductions.
Similarly,
I ended up at one point introduced
to Garrett Camp and I advise,
Stumble upon, stumble
upon, didn't work out, uh,
but we had a chance to
work together extensively.
And then what a Garrett camp go on to do.
He started this thing that people
laughed at called Uber Cab Llc,
which then got renamed.
It became Uber. Right?
So that at least on paper
has worked out very well.
That's more important than clawbacks.
Yeah. More important than club. Uh,
so first and foremost, thank you for, uh,
shepherding me even as a
viewer are a quick study,
as much of a blunt instrument
as I was into all of that.
But can you tell us about some of the
responses from the venture capitalists,
these rejections? Like what happened?
Can you tell us about a meat?
You don't have to name names, but like,
you know, meetings go, I don't blame him.
I mean, uh, I had never made an angel
investment before I was from Austin,
Texas. I had no network here.
I just show up saying, hey,
I think I want to be a VC and,
um, you know, let's not a,
not a very straight
forward path. Um, and so,
you know, I would call up
sequoia capital and say, Hey,
I'd like to interview for a job.
It's sequoia capital.
And that's just not how it really
works. And so, um, you know,
I have no animus towards
anybody. Like they probably, um,
you know,
they probably made the right decision at
the time for what their parameters were.
See you have a characteristic,
it seems,
at least in the way you express yourself,
that I don't see in a lot of people.
And that is, you seem to
hold very, very few grudges.
I don't think I've ever heard you
express ill will towards anyone.
Uh, especially in this day
and age. But that's a rarity.
Is that something that
you've always had by,
by birth or is that something
you developed? Why is
that? It's a waste of time.
But how did you learn that? How did
you embody this? Because if you,
uh,
I, I dunno, I Kinda, I kinda
look at it like life is short.
You don't have much time.
Every day is a gift. And the,
the part of the secret of happiness is
to figure out what your gift is and to
offer it to the world and to like not
worry about all the noise and the hype
around you that says what you should do.
You know,
think for yourself and don't
waste any energy on this stuff.
It doesn't matter to you.
And holding a grudge is a symptom of not
knowing how you want to spend the gift
of today. And so, uh,
you know, it's hard to,
it's hard to hold a grudge if you're,
if you're so focused on,
I'm excited about these things,
I can do a good job at this.
I can't wait to do this stuff. How do
you have time for grudges? It's just,
it just doesn't make sense.
Right. It doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
I mean, I, there was a few
people, you know, you know,
just be honest, but you know,
when she, you land in
Silicon Valley Sequoia, like,
and it wasn't just a quiet,
no, no. I don't know.
I probably shaped there and that's the
reason I'm just saying I'm singling them
out because I was taking a fling at an
impossible dream. And Sequoia was like,
Hey,
Harvard,
I want early acceptance to start and I
want to start in the middle of the year,
even though I don't have the
prereqs. I mean, in a sense. Right.
And I had no resume, no grades.
That's a hard pitch. Yeah. Uh,
and they're really good at what they
do. It turns out it was, yeah. Yeah.
But you land here,
you don't get the jobs.
You are given this,
this gift of an introduction through
Ron with really smart wordsmithing.
Hope you guys were listening.
Like the pitch is really,
really important and nuanced. You
ended up meeting Kevin Rose. So you,
you invest in Evan now at the time, was
it Twitter or was it, was Odo is podio?
So walk us through how that unfolded.
Well, um, I thought, you know, I was in
Austin and what I would do is, you know,
my kids were in grade school and so
we weren't sure whether to move yet.
So I would come out every Sunday
night and stay over Thursday.
And it's funny cause when you're
on that pattern on the plane,
some of the same people are on the plane,
like system integrator, consultants,
people from Deloitte and stuff. And I'd
be like, oh, it's the brother that's,
hey bud, what's up?
What's going on? But, uh,
so I'd be on these plane flights and all
these people and we would, um, we would,
uh, I did go from Monday to Thursday and
this is always dangerous when I got the
bottle. Liquid courage.
Yeah. But, but, um, uh,
and so I thought, okay, I'm gonna,
I'm going to take nine months and figure
out if I can find something exciting
and Silicon Valley.
So I just basically immigrated here.
And the reason that I did that was that
I thought the web was shifting from a,
an internet of connected pages to a
platform that would connect people.
And it just felt like it was kind of time
to get the party started again on the
Internet. You know, the bubble had burst,
the meltdown had happened
and I saw things happen.
I saw Tim O'reilly talk
about web two auto,
I saw stuff about podcasting and
broad catching and stuff like that.
And I was like,
it's just clear to me,
this is just obvious that something major
news happening and I just have to go
to California. I have to go right
now, not wait another day. And so,
so I do that and as I've had the best
podcasting company and so I, you know,
Jeff Huber it,
Google introduced me to him.
He said we just ran him off because he
doesn't want to work at a big company,
but he's going to do something
interesting podcasting.
And Somehow Evan took my money his first
time ever since he took your money.
But walk us step by the way, that's
a pretty good start. And investing,
that's a fantastic Williams did
Kevin Rose, it's not bad. You know,
you could argue that the secret to
ventures to get lucky and your first five
years, which I think is a pretty strong
argument, I think it's a huge argument,
but you, you've, you've since
then been like consistent,
I should correct me if I'm wrong,
but with Odeo there was a,
was there a point when as it was a very
good guy decided to offer investors the
ability to, to get their money back? Yeah,
so what happened was I'm so
invested in Odeo and Mike, okay,
great best podcasting company,
first Angel Investment I've ever made.
Just wire the money in a week later,
apple decides they're going to
give away podcasting on iTunes.
And at the time,
it's hard to remember now,
but 85% of all playback
devices where iPods. So like,
what are we going to be the the, the one
you pay for on the Zune, right? Like,
it's like, what business? Like
you don't have a business.
There's still people trying. It's so, so,
so a f to his credit tried for about
a year to figure out another business.
And um,
we couldn't,
and we'd go brainstorm and we'd look
at each other and we're like, yeah,
it's pretty tough. And, and, uh, and um,
and so one day is some of the investors
were getting pretty disenchanted because
they're like, you're just wasting our
money. You know, there's no business here.
And so f decides to give it
back to everybody. And so, uh,
so I'm like, look, have you
know, you don't owe me anything.
Venture capital is in the word has
venture in it and you win some,
you lose some. Right? He goes,
well this is the kind of the deal I've
struck with some of the bigger investors
and B, it would help me a lot if you
just went along with it. And so I said,
well as long as you let me invest
in your next thing. And he goes,
well part of this deal is I get to keep
this Ip that I've been working on on the
side and we're trying to decide whether
to call it voicemail 2.0 or tw TTR and
it's one of Jack is working on it long
with Noah and we're figuring this out.
And I'm like,
what is,
I'm like come on voicemail 2.0 in like
why don't you put the vowels back in?
Cause like Twitter without the vowel
sounds like flicker and that's derivative
and whatever. So I don't think I had
anything to do with that by the way,
but like I was just my gut
reaction. So he goes, ah,
you say what you're doing. And I'm
like, well then what? Ha. Okay. Yeah.
Then what happens?
He goes at 140 characters or less cause
we want it to do cell phones and stuff.
And I'm like, this is before the
iPhone, right? So, so I'm like, okay.
And then what happens? He's like, he's
like, that's it. That's all it does.
And I say, uh, uh, what's the roadmap?
There is no roadmap and a,
what's the revenue model?
There is no revenue model.
And so I say a math,
uh, like, why do you even think this is a
product? Much less a business, a company.
And he goes, oh, I have no
idea if it is. But he goes,
here's the way I'm thinking about it.
Like blogger,
a million people use blogger software and
this is EBS. First company was blogger,
he was one of the pioneers of blogging.
He goes, podcasting's kind of hard.
You had to use audio studio,
you had to record stuff,
you had to put it on an RSS feed. He's
like, it just took more effort. He's like,
what happens if you had micro blogs
and rather than a million people did
microblogs 10 million people did.
Microblogs he's like,
I think if 10 million people
did microblogs the burden
of proof will be on the
people who are negative. And so I
was like, sounds good to me. Uh,
I'd like to invest in Twitter or voicemail
2.0, whatever you call this thing.
And, uh, and he says, well,
it's, you know, it's not a
company. There is no investment.
But, uh, and then, and then a few months
later, uh, maybe six months later,
Twitter blows up at south by, which
is such a delicious irony, right?
Cause it's from Austin, right?
The town I just come from.
And a couple of weeks later, [inaudible]
says, hey. And I thought by then,
it's like a hot air balloon drifting away.
There's no way I'm going to get to invest,
you know,
abs going to forgotten and
everybody's gonna be chasing him.
And he calls me up one day and says,
hey,
did you mean it when you said you wanted
to invest in a Twitter? And I said, yeah.
And he goes, well, um,
we're about to take our first money and
if you want to do that, now's the time.
Wow. Yeah, that was a good
guy. He is. So like I,
I remember that because both of those
guys were good to me. You know, like
I just some random Joe Schmo
guy and both of them, uh,
you know, gave me a chance to be
involved in their companies and uh,
yeah,
that good guys and the RC,
I try to remember that every time an
entrepreneur pitches us. I, you know,
I try to remember the
grace those guys showed me
and our stories intertwined in so many
ways because that I met him right around
the time we were hanging out on this
book and 2007 South by southwest,
I begged and pleaded with Hugh Forrest
who was running south by interactive,
or at least the programming
side still is, it still is. And,
and now a neighbor of mine effectively.
And I begged and plead, I said,
if you have any last minute,
can't,
I know you don't have any spots because
I've already been rejected multiple
times.
But if you have a cancellation,
if there's anything that moves and
there's a spot, please let me know.
I'd love the opportunity.
And Lo and behold,
there was this chance 2007 which at the
time to put it in perspective, Twitter,
all of the tweets in the world were
being displayed on these big screen TVs.
They were positioned
around the conference hall,
just one feed moving kind of slowly.
Every Twitter user,
I was briefly in the top 100 I was very
proud of that until Ashton Kutcher came
along, just like kicked
my head around and I do,
I never cracked the top 100 donated,
only needed like 500 at one point.
And then it was gone. But it should have
been Mike at Twitter. But I was like,
oh come on. Like how there are so many
people who have that story. They're like,
oh I just chose like Hawaii steak 5.0 is
my username cause who it's not going to
become anything. And then again, I'm
stuck with that for the rest of my life.
But I ended up getting an
email from you and he's like,
Hey, if you meant it, like we have an
overflow room that had a cancellation,
a sponsor isn't going to do, they're
stuck. So if you want it 45 minutes,
you blew up at south by
two. I did. And uh, it was,
what was really funny about it is I was
so nervous of sooner versus my first
presentation really about the book.
And it was before the book came out.
The book came out in April,
2007. This was in March,
and I was staying at a friend's
place because I couldn't,
I wasn't gonna pay for the hotels. They're
all sold out. Also, if you get a room,
and it's like $1,000 a
night during south by,
so I stayed in my friend's house and I
would go into his garage and I rehearsed
my talk in front of his three Chihuahuas
and I'll explain, I'll explain why
a, my friend had other things to do and
he had real jobs so he wasn't going to be
there.
But the Chihuahua's you had to be at
least like 10% Tony Robbins to keep them
engaged. And, and these
dogs at your secret,
is that your seat?
I can be 10% Tony Robbins.
I'm doing pretty fewer in
tribe of mentors. Would you,
that would be your like talk like
it's saying, here's my district.
My secret trick for networking is first
practice with dogs because they don't
care about the content so much, but if
you're monotone they just kind of go, ah,
and then turn around
and walk away.
So I was in the garage and I'm like kind
of doing this hand wavy stuff to keep
them engaged. This, I
totally believe this. Oh No.
I remember the garage and then I go
to the event and I had all these fancy
slides and everything prepared and
what happens? Blue screen of death,
my computer died and sell my,
okay,
well I guess I'm just going to have
to do this without any of my prompts.
And I did it, but I'd rehearsed so much
that I had it in my head. And uh, yeah.
So Hugh also one of those
people, it's like, to this
day, if you ever asks me like,
Hey, could you help us with x, Y, Z,
go south pine? It's like, of course,
of course I will because it's
just like that one opportunity.
And I also want to emphasize one thing.
He'll look and say, well, you know,
the luck was there with Twitter at the
same time and it was absolutely lucky.
But it's like every year there
is something to draft on.
Like every month there's something like
that that you can draft and you just
have to look for it, but you're going
to the other. Well the other thing is,
it's kind of, I guess we talked
about grudges earlier. To me,
like the opposite of having a grudge is
like to enjoy seeing somebody do well.
Right? And like, um,
when when I was a founder or you're
just trying to do real company stuff and
make the company happen and you're like,
okay,
we're going to go on this ride
and hopefully it works out.
But one of the fun things about being
an investor is you get to see people do
well. You know, you get to see,
you know, like Logan and John, uh,
from Lyft ate beans until
they raised their seed round.
And when we had our first board meeting
and looks at the financials and says,
you guys aren't paying yourselves and
minimum wage and that's illegal in
California. It was like, we have to
fix that. And so, so like, and now,
now people talk about how much money
Lyft has and Al Carl Icahn's invested in
Google capital, but like, like I remember
him when they were eating beans. Right.
And, and, um, and it's just
fun to see them do that. Well,
it's fun to see you do this well,
right? I mean it's like, um,
we had no reason to think the four hour
work week was going to be that big a
deal. I mean, you hope it will.
We a lot of reasons to believe it
wouldn't be a big deal. But I mean,
it was like seven or just like
every time I see, you know,
I'll get a call from somebody
like a reporter that says, Hey,
would you do a quote for this article
about Tim and some major publication.
I'm like, wow, he's just killing
it. That's awesome. Right?
And it's just fun to see.
It's a lot more fun to spend your energy
on deriving joy from that and seeing
your friends do well,
especially friends who were like worthy
of doing well and won't be changed by it.
Like that's a lot more fun than
remembering who wasn't nice along the way,
you know? Yeah. It's a drag. I've,
I've been working on the grudge piece.
I don't have many, but
it's good to see you. Yeah,
I mean like the Arab spring
or like when I would,
I'd pick up Sloan on a play date,
you know, my daughter Sloan and,
and the parents or the play date would
say, is it true you invested in Twitter?
I saw them on Oprah and then the
Arab spring happened and I was like,
wow, this company is kind of working like
we got a chance to do well on this one.
You see, you mentioned
your daughter. I want to
bring up something that I've thought a
lot about since you mentioned it to me
and as context for folks.
What I've really tried to do in the last
at least five years is to look at the
lives of people I look up to in a
holistic way before modeling them.
All right?
So what I mean by that is
it's tempting to look at say the business
success of person x and then replicate
everything they do.
But all you may see is one
tiny piece of the puzzle.
And then in actuality they walk around
in shambles and every other capacities.
So I've,
I've tried with the interviews and the
books and tribe of mentors to really look
at things holistically.
And I remember asking and I asked,
even though I don't have kids,
I ask parenting advice of friends a lot
because I'm curious to see how they look
at it.
And at one point I asked you when we were
on a hike and I asked you what advice
you would give to a new parent or
someone thinking about becoming a parent.
And please correct me if
I'm getting this wrong,
but I might write your
version is going to be better.
But to my recollection,
there were two main points that you made
and there there could be more be you
said,
number one,
really teach your kids and train them
to be optimists because without that
you're lost.
And with that you can at least look for
a CE solutions and silver lining and so
forth. And then the second part was
remember that your kids owe you nothing.
Like they didn't ask to be
born. You chose, remember, wow,
I do remember it was meaningful to me.
I really made an imprint.
And your job is to give them love.
It is not their job to give you love.
That's right. The, I chose to have
them, they didn't choose to have me.
They owe me nothing. Yeah. And, uh,
like I find it helpful to think
about that. But, but like the, the,
the, the hope part I think
is, is important for them.
Like the, the, the way I
look at it is, unfortunately,
unless we solve some breakthrough problem,
we're all going to die.
So you could choose to be to fetus
about that. Or you can choose to say,
the fact that we get to live at all
is just this huge gift. And so like,
I think that one of the things that you
can do for your kids as you can help
them feel optimistic and happy about
the fact that they have the gift to be
alive and that,
um,
don't be defeatist about this world.
You had the gift of today and as
long as you have the gifted today,
like you should be like, you're,
you're on the path to the light. Right.
And, um, uh, and if you can,
if you can give your kids the gift of
being optimistic and hopeful about the
future and grateful that they have
the time they're going to have, like,
I think that that's helpful
for them because kids get,
they get judged and you know,
all of us
are unkind to ourselves in our own mind.
And we're judged by people all the time.
And it's easy to just forget
that just today's a gift.
Be grateful for that gift to be optimistic
that tomorrow's gonna be another day
where you have another gift. So when your
kids or say one of your entrepreneurs,
I mean, yeah, startups are full
contact sport, right? I mean, yeah,
people take their lumps and in major
ways and bad things happen all the time.
Uh,
whether it's with your kids or some of
the founders you've worked with when
they're going through really rough time,
what do you, what do you say to them? Uh,
and it,
you could give a specific example
or just a general principle.
Then I'd be curious to hear
how you'd think about that. Um,
well, so, so like these
founders that we've worked,
some of them are just
extraordinary, right? And so I, uh,
I'm reluctant to say we
had much of an impact. Um,
I think the thing that
sometimes I've done, uh,
that I've been proud of is
like when they're in the
depths of despair, you know,
entrepreneurship is like this where
there's no, there's no even path.
And, uh, there are times
where you just like,
everything is against you and you're just
like, how did I get myself into this?
And this is so terrible. Uh, and, um,
I think I've been better than most
at those times. It kind of saying,
you've got this, how do
you, how, and sometimes,
and sometimes they need to hear that.
Is it just the words or how do you
deliver it? Like what makes no, I tell,
I tell them, look, you know, Twitter,
we couldn't keep the servers running.
We couldn't decide who the CEO was.
A twitch,
it was Justin TV.
We didn't even know what twitch was.
That's during the Chegg was
craigslist for colleges.
And then Facebook decided
to compete with us.
So we pivoted textbook rentals and
we only had 30 days left of cash.
And like Ng Moco,
we had 45 days of cash when
we pivoted from APP downloads,
the free to play and Lyft started out
as Zimride and when we launched Lyft,
we weren't even sure it was legal.
So I'm like,
guys like guys I've seen way
crazier than this. You got this.
And sometimes a founder needs to know,
look,
entrepreneurship on.
So I like,
I like to say I like to invest in people
I would enjoy getting in trouble with
because it happens every time.
And um,
and like when you're in trouble with these
people, what's it going to feel like?
Is it going to feel like, okay,
it's us against the world,
or is it going to feel like, oh, how did
I get myself involved with these people?
And so like, I like people where I'm
like, we're in the foxhole together,
screw the rest of the world and what
they think we're right. They're wrong,
let's rock and roll. Right. And
so, um, so that's kind of, uh,
I think that we've been like,
I like to say when I was an entrepreneur,
one of the things I learned
is in my early customers,
they didn't just buy what I was selling,
they bought because they believed
what I believed we were in on a secret
together.
And like when I work with founders,
I like to say I'm in on a secret with the,
I believe they're secret.
And like we think the rest
of the world is just wrong.
We think we're right and we're going to
prove it. And so when stuff goes wrong,
we're like, Eh, it's just a
setback, speed, bump, whatever. But,
but like in the end it's
like we still believe in our
insight. We're right. Let's,
let's prove it.
Let's prove it.
What about for yourself,
if you can think of in the
last decades could be anything,
but when,
when you,
could you give us an example of maybe a
tough time that you went through and how
you found your way out of
it? Or what helped you find
way out of it could be any,
any set of life? Gosh, a fair number.
Um, you know, Liz, Liz and
I broke up, uh, you know,
we'd been married for 17 years
and things didn't work out.
And that just felt like, um, like,
like I had really failed as a person
and I was about to fail as a dad and,
you know, like, uh, what else? Uh,
what else was there if I failed at those
things and then what can I even think I
was successful at? That was
a, that was a tough time.
Um, but, but, um, you
know, fortunately, uh,
kiddos turned out okay. And, um,
you know, I tried the hardest.
I could navigate that time the
best I could. And, you know,
kids turned out great and Liz and I
get along just fine and, you know,
you win some, you lose some.
But, but at that point in time,
it just felt like everything I had done
in his life was screwed up and I just
totally blown it.
How did you not just succumb to the
depths of despair and stay there?
Yeah. And some day, you know, we,
we need to have some more
wine and talk about this,
cause I know you've said that you've,
you've struggled right.
At times with feeling depressed and um,
I'm like the worst person to talk to
depress people because I just don't
understand the concept like, like a,
and it's like I'm not judging right.
But like I'm, I'm just like, um, uh,
today's a gift and like I have to like
make the most I can out of it and if it
doesn't work out,
make the most out of [inaudible].
And by the way,
like I don't look at that like,
I don't think that my way of thinking
is better than your way of thinking.
Like it's sort of like you're leaner
than I am. You could probably run faster,
jump higher. I don't sit there and
say, give me your legs. Right. I,
I just realized that we're all
different and I realized that,
that like I've had a few blessings in
life and one of them is to be grateful for
every day. And, and like for
that to be the high order bit,
no matter what's happening, I'm like,
you got to have today. So did that,
was that just a life raft that you had
throughout that entire period that each
morning you'd remind yourself over? How
did it manifest on it's daily. It just,
it's just ever presence. Just
ever Pr. It's just obvious to me.
It's like breathing oxygen and I need to
borrow your code. All right. Yeah. But,
but I don't say that it's like, listen
to me and my advice, I'm so smart.
It's just I was lucky enough to
be configured in wired that way.
So I want to make a suggestion
to everyone in the audience,
and this is based on observing
Mike over and over again.
When someone says to you, well,
you can explain it to me. I'm just,
I'm a not a fast thinker. I'm from
Texas. When someone pulls that,
you should really be careful. And, uh,
I actually borrowed that from you and
I was like, I think I can use this.
Cause most people think people
from Long Island are idiots. Great.
So I'll be like, you know, explain
it to me again because I'm not clear.
My brain doesn't move that fast and from
Long Island. And everyone's like, what?
And then so thank you for allowing me to,
that I could help you act simple.
So I wanted to bring up,
and this is actually something
we have not spoken about
publicly or privately before,
but commander John Boyd. Yeah.
Can you explain who commander
John Boyd is and why you're a fan?
Yeah. So, um, uh, commander John Boyd was,
I'm a flight instructor
for the Air Force and he,
there was this expression that in
a simulated dog fight, he could,
he could beat any pilot in like 30 seconds
or some outrageously quick amount of
time. And people were like, well,
how does he do that? And he taught,
he taught this form of combat, which
was about moving very quickly. And,
um,
uh,
so it's if you place yourself in the
time I was reading about John Boyd,
it was also when I was working
with Eric Reese and Steve Blank.
And so Eric Reese was a
consultant at floodgate before
he wrote the lean startup.
He's famous just like I have
this magnetism for famous
future to be authors I
guess. But, but, uh, so we,
we were talking to and we're like
something really important happening here.
Offshore Labor or search engine marketing,
opensource software,
broadband penetration,
global markets.
And it seems like you can get a
product to market for less money.
You can do it faster.
And uh,
Steve Blank started talking
about this guy named John Boyd.
And so John Boy does this
flight instructor in the
Air Force and he could beat
anybody in a dog fight super fast.
And Boyd's fundamental insight was that
sometimes you can win a battle purely by
being faster.
So like,
let's say you're in a Russian Mig and
I'm in an f 16 and I make the wrong move,
but you haven't moved yet.
And then I make the right
moves before you've moved yet.
Just the mere fact that I was able to
make a move and course correct before made
your countermove means two things.
I can get in the right position
relative to you. But more importantly,
it's very disorienting to you cause
you don't know where I am. I was here,
now I'm there.
And so the,
the philosophy of John boy
that was inspiring to me
back in 2005 and one of the
reasons I started
floodgate was I was like,
you can do this as an
entrepreneur and an investor.
And so the f 16 fighter jet was designed
to John Boyd Spec and f 16 doesn't fly
faster than Russian Mig, but it
changes directions faster. It's,
so the [inaudible] fighter was a system.
It wasn't just the plain,
which could change direction faster.
It was the mind of the pilot and the mind
of an agile pilot with an agile plane
will be to mush, beat a Russian
Mig all day long. And so, um,
so I was like, that's what's
going to happen with startups.
And that's why 500,000 is the new 5
million. And that's why we need to go fun,
these agile entrepreneurs,
because they're going to be able to
force multiply and the big competitors
who've raised a bunch of money or going
slower doing waterfall development,
they're going to be disoriented by
how fast these companies move. And so,
like what,
what,
what I really learned from Boyd was
the kind of this idea that if you,
if you are a speed based competitor,
uh,
you can be wrong but still be right
quicker, which makes you, right,
right?
Which,
which translates very directly to
blank and Eric Reese and that's right.
Minimum buyable product and iterating.
You could,
you could be totally off
base in the beginning,
which a lot of your biggest hits have
been in the 93% of our exit profits have
come from pivots. And so, you know,
you look at that and you say, Gosh,
when we invest, should we even
care what the business is? I mean,
it's a legitimate question.
So like cruise automation,
right? That's one of our recent wins.
Uh, you know, Kyle had started twitch,
we made a bunch of money on twitch and uh,
he starts this company called cruise.
It's like a roof rack that does
autopilot self driving. I'm like, Kyle,
that's a bad idea because you're going
to live 20 customers in the world.
There's only 20 car companies that
matter and they have concentrated buying
power and they can design you out unless
you're like 10 times better and there's
gonna be competition, blah, blah, blah.
So six months later he's like, okay,
you're right. The roof rack idea was
dumb. I've got this new idea. I'm like,
what's your new idea? Is like, I'm
going to make Nissan leafs self driving.
And I'm like, then why are you
gonna do? He's like, well, you know,
there's a lot of ways you can monetize
that. You can do a fleet of cars,
you can sell the cars people
you do. So I'm like, okay,
let me get this straight column.
Now you're just going to
compete against everybody there.
You compete against Uber and Lyft
and Tesla and GM and everybody, Bosh.
He's like, yeah, but you know,
I'm passionate about this.
I've been doing this since MIT is
my research project. And I've just,
I just think this the way to go.
And I sat there and I thought
about it and I was like, you know,
this guy made me 84 times on my
money last time I wrote him a check,
I think I'm just going to run
them in check. So, uh, so I,
so I go to the partner meeting at
floodgate and thank God you don't have,
we don't have a voting system.
And I say, I say, you know,
I think I've decided I'm
going to do this cruise deal.
And everybody reads me the riot act
and they're like, Mike, come on.
Like I understand that a
business model can be vague,
but like you cannot even articulate a
path where this is a business and neither
can Kyle. And I was like,
no, but you don't understand.
And he's an awesome founder.
He's got incredible insights, he's
very passionate, blah, blah blah.
So like everybody just is like, talk
to the hand, this is stupid, whatever.
So we had two new, uh, venture partners
who became partners, Ryan and Arjun.
And six months later they get bought by
GM for more than a billion dollars. And,
um, Ryan and Arjun go,
boy, it's really a shame.
We talked you out of this cruise deal.
And I said, oh, we funded crews. And
so, uh, like of course we funded it.
I secretly have super voting rights on
every deal. No, we, it at floodgate,
there's no voting system.
It's just somebody has to pound the table.
And so if somebody pounds
the table and says,
I will take ownership of this and I
am responsible for the outcome of our
returns to deal happens. But if everybody
around the tables and a minus and says,
I think this is a good deal for you to do,
Tim or you to do an or you to do,
Ryan are you to do origin.
But nobody says I will pound the table.
I'm irrationally love with this
doesn't happen. So like we, you know,
we kind of think that in the super
early stage, kind of love conquers all.
And it's like, you know, when you're
going through all these times are good,
getting all his trouble.
It's your love for the idea
and the founder that will
cause you to like overcome
whatever you face.
And you have to have enough authentic
love and passion for the idea and the
founders that you're willing to pound
the table and say, I will defend this.
I will defend 140 characters or less,
even though people say
it's stupid in 2007 right.
So just need,
you just need one person who is,
who in some cases irrationally exuberant
and willing to defend the idea for a go
signal for sure. And then, uh, so this
is, this is really fascinating to me.
Yeah. We're not exactly a
private equity shop. No,
but it strikes me that some of
the best investors I know have a,
a similar or close
cousin approach to that.
Like if they have somebody who's
willing to just put it all on the line,
who's already been vetted because they
were hired as a partner, it's like, okay,
kid, like it's on you then. No. But
if they're really willing to go,
go to go to fight for it. And, and by the
way, like if you're a partner, floodgate,
yeah, you pound the table. But guess
what? We keep track of the deals you did.
And if you like lose tens of
millions of dollars of no returns.
It's nothing personal, but like you
just don't seem to be cut out for this.
You're not like pound our table anymore.
So like when I pound the table for a deal,
I know just as much as any other partner
that I am taking ownership of pounding
the table and we're going to all help
each other and we're not going to say,
yeah, I told you so. But it's
like if I pound the table,
I'm saying I care enough about this
idea that I'm willing to have some of my
track record and
credibility be tied to this.
How do you differentiate? If
you look at, for instance,
93% of the returns coming from
companies that pivoted. Yeah.
When you are observing a founder or trying
to help and just by way of giving the
most convoluted question possible.
Okay.
Question I get a lot is how do I
know when to persist with my idea?
How do I know when to quit or
how do I know when to pivot?
That's a hard question to answer.
But when I spoke with Marc
Andreessen awhile while back
for the podcast, he said,
you know, sometimes people pivot so
often. It's like every time I see them,
I'm paraphrasing here, it's like
watching a rabbit good down in a maze.
It's like every two days
it's a different company.
It's like they think it's a Mulligan,
not a pivot. Right? So how do you,
how do you help guide or even assess a,
a good pivot versus someone
who's merely unfocused? Yeah.
So, um, uh, and, and you know,
it could be that I've just been had
a string of crazy beginner's luck.
And so that is a very real potential
factor. Yeah. But, but, um,
uh, the way I see it is that, uh,
you are right when,
when not because people agree with you,
you are right or wrong based on whether
you're first principles thinking is
right or wrong. And so if I see
a company where it's not working,
but I still believe in the first
principles of the idea, I say,
this is great.
We still believe in the first principles
and we know more than we knew a year
ago.
That's a fundamental advantage.
Like why would we want not want to double
down on that? And so, uh, whereas what,
what happens too often as you say,
this doesn't work,
it doesn't have traction and we're not
gonna be able to raise money, you know,
forget about it.
And the problem with that is that if you
live with the results of other people's
thinking, it's, it's like if
somebody really smart like fight,
you know,
I guess if Reid Hoffman says to me,
this is a bad network effects idea,
because if it doesn't conform to network
theory in these ways, unlike, okay,
that's data. He's the smartest
network effects guy. No,
the best PR first principles thinker
about network effects. I know.
And I offered a first
principle to him that he said,
you're wrong on first principles. I'm
like, hm, I pry all listen to that.
Uh,
but like if somebody like with Chegg,
right when we did textbook
rouse people said, oh,
people try that before with varsity books.
And like,
who gives a shit? That was five years
ago, like five years ago, isn't it today?
And so like, um, like to me
it's about like what are,
what are just your first principles,
reasoning behind why you're excited
about something and are your first
principles,
reasons being refuted or double down on.
Because to me the valid definition of a
pivot is the first principles are still
true,
but you learned something from the data
on the ground that caused you to double
down on a new aspect of that that nobody
else knows God and see have in Split.
But like that may just me be giving a
good explanation for why I got lucky.
That is perfectly reasonable point
of view for you to take. Yeah,
I mean it's certainly possible.
Uh,
I would tend to assess it as
certainly a component of skill.
But if you're looking at then let's
just take you of the first principles.
Maybe then you have strategy,
then you have tactics and you have
tools you could look at a stack.
Are the first principles in your
investing experience? Mostly spotting,
say converging trends that people
haven't spotted before. What,
what would be an example of first
principles as it applies to one of these?
Will you surf? Do you surf poorly?
Orally I surf even more poorly but,
but like I like the Metaphor of surfing
because you could be a skilled surfer
but you don't really control surfing,
right?
You can sort of control the board ish.
Even if you're good,
you can only barely control it,
but you can't control the wave.
And like I look at the w to me the magic
that animates the tech industry is a
combination of Moore's law,
Metcalf's law.
And so I think we all benefit from the
magic of Moore's law Metcalf's law and
it's like literally as powerful as the
ocean waves and below you when you surf.
And so like I look at it like the job
of a startup founder is to surf a valid
wave and the wave is usually
bigger than the company, right?
Like when we invest in Lyft and crews,
we had this belief that network capitalism
is supplanting vertically integrated
corporations and that there would be
network transportation and just like I
believe there's going to be networked
real estate network manufacturing,
all this stuff.
And so we believe that those gathering
waves are more powerful than any one
company. And that the, the,
the job of the tech entrepreneur is to
leverage the awesome massive power of all
of the,
you know,
all of the fury of the ocean beneath them
of Moore's law and Metcalf's law just
surf into the beach and you know,
like give Moore's law enough time,
it will breach the advantage
of any incumbent and give
Metcalf's law enough time
and it will create an insurmountable mote.
Google tried to take out
Twitter with Jaiku didn't work.
It didn't matter because Twitter,
I had a network effect and so like to
me like the tech industry's magical,
like there's been tulips in the past.
There's been a crash of 29 there's
been the real estate bubble,
there's bubbles all the time.
There's mania is all the time,
but tech is animated by two
valid exponential forces
that are super powerful and
they are the asymmetric attack vector
of the entrepreneur. They are the,
they're the Rock in David's slingshot.
And so,
uh,
I look for founders who have some type
of fundamental contrarian insight about
where a wave's about to gather and then
hopefully they have the stuff to surf it.
And if they do, I'm like, hey, let's
raw unconditional love. Let's go.
Will you, you gave me some
related advice really early on.
I remember meeting more by
the way. Any more wine? Yeah.
Think I think I have a wine deficiency.
Yes. We'd love to see out wine. Gotcha.
Thank you.
You gave me some advice.
I remember it was at a restaurant
in Palo Alto. There was, uh,
an event gathering.
Reid Hoffman was speaking,
I was attending and we were having wine
much like we're having right now. And we,
you're talking about some
deal I was flummoxed by,
because I had certain primitive
parameters for investing and I was getting
somewhat ridiculed for my
simplistic parameters. Like,
I need to be a power user of the product.
I need to,
it needs to match with the demographic,
that sort of core audience than I have.
And I got a lot of flack for it. And I
remember he said to me, well if those are,
say you didn't use these words then,
but like your first principles as are
your sort of criteria. If you fall,
you're going to make,
in some cases really good investments
when people are poopooing the idea,
but it perfectly matches.
So your criteria when it's,
when their sprints, right, based
on first principles. Conversely,
if it doesn't match your first principles
and you're getting into a deal because
it's closing tomorrow, but we can
feel it, you feel or whatever,
if you're just following some consensus,
however small,
but it doesn't conform
to your first principles,
that's where you gonna lose your money.
Yeah.
This is where like people
talk about social proof.
I think social proof is
bullshit. I think that it's, um,
so my favorite example is
actually an Elon Musk example. So,
I don't know if some of you may have
heard this, but I thought you can say,
I think some of you may have heard
of him. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Uh, so,
so,
um,
he talks about space x and most people
think space x is like a better NASA,
but that's not true. So you
think about a rocket, um,
what 0.3% of the cost of the rocket is
the fuel and the rest of it is what gets
burned up in space when it doesn't
come back. So Ilan says, okay,
if you could have a reusable
rocket you could have,
you could maintain 99.7% of the value
of the rocket by bringing it back to
Earth.
And if you could do that,
you could have a two orders
of magnitude improvement.
The economics of space travel,
that's first principles thinking.
Or when f says if 10 million people,
right? Microblogs that's 10 times more.
The burden of proof is on the people
that are negative. And so like,
I don't have to see the
business plan to say,
that's an insight I can
get behind. Right. Uh,
conversely all see plenty of business
plans that look incredibly straightforward
and I eliminate them immediately because
they're just not an exponential enough
and they're not first principles enough
in my whole business isn't about how,
how often I lose. It's the magnitude
of the rightness when I win.
And so like I, when I, when I
have to win super freaking big,
this is a such an important point. And
because it applies to life and not just,
well it depends. Like if you're a PE
guy, you don't want to have anybody,
you don't want more than private equity.
You don't want to have more than like a
15% loss ratio. Sure. So you're, you're,
you want to take out risk and you want,
but I'm not a risk taker outer,
I'm a luck multiplier,
right?
Like I'm not asking what
can go wrong because I'm
investing when it's worth zero,
I'm asking what could go spectacularly,
right.
Is a rare event and I only have to
be right a fair number of times.
As long as the idea has the exponential
awesome power to just take us to the
promised land.
Well,
this is part of what appealed to me about
the startup game as you explained it
to me,
because it's a hits driven business.
You can be wrong a lot,
but if you have decent rules
that have some basis in reality,
maybe you, maybe, maybe then you,
as long as you're,
this is,
we don't have to get into like
portfolio theory and stuff, but yeah,
as long as you're investing enough in
these bets that they can say return the
fund or whatever the parameters might
be, it's a, it's a fun game. Uh,
and uh,
it's certainly dangerous one.
But let me ask you this because I remember
how impactful and then we're going to
go to audience Q and a. My, in my,
my, my pink basket that I brought,
uh, if you are teaching,
you can pick the age.
It could be college, freshmen,
college, senior of high school, senior,
doesn't really matter.
Graduate School,
if you were teaching a
class on entrepreneurship.
So you're not teaching
people how to be investors.
So we do now we teach wants Stanford. Oh,
you do? Okay, well that makes this easy.
So what do you teach?
What are,
what are the sort of
differentiators in the class? Um,
what we, what we try to do is
help people understand that
there are things that we can learn from
these prime mover entrepreneurs who
create massive abundance. And it's about
more than just having a good product,
product market fit clearly important,
but designing the company,
what's your culture?
How are you going to define it up
front or just kind of let it happen?
What's your category?
Or are you going to design your category?
Just let it happen.
Are you going to chase revenue or are
you going to accumulate attractive
customers? And so like what we
try to, what we try to emphasize,
we try to emphasize a couple of things.
One is
great businesses truly are valuable and
so we should try to think about building
a scale of the business with the truth
value in mind rather than what's the
latest fad and how do we raise money or
what's the paper Unicorn or any of that
stuff.
But then the other thing that we,
we worry about some is that you look at
some of these companies and the problems
they've had with their culture and a lot
of these people come from Stanford or
the top schools and it's like it
how do we have some impact where if,
if, if only one person who might have
gone off the rails as a founder in that
dimension doesn't. Because we're
like, you know, culture matters.
A building company foundation matters
how people treat each other matters and
some of this stuff is like a blockchain
transaction. You'd get it wrong.
You can't go backwards or
like the metaphor I like to
use like the Hertz rental
car parking lot, if you back up
the tires explode and so you can't,
some of this stuff you
can't really back up.
And so getting it right the first time,
there's a lot of counterintuitive lessons
and it's more about just having a good
product. It's about designing a company
in a category in addition to the product.
And you know,
having a point of view about how you're
going to bring abundance to the world
and not just get rich.
And so the class is sort of
about that and about just like,
oh, the other ideas that like you
don't, if you're a prime mover,
you don't just have to be a tech
entrepreneur. Like you could be, uh, uh,
the French laundry guy who Keller
Thomas Selling. You can be, uh,
Elvis Presley and you invent rock and
roll. Or you can be Albert Einstein.
You can have a theory or um,
you know,
MLK out a dream.
But it's sort of the idea that we try to
express to people is find your gift and
express it your way.
And um,
entrepreneurship is only one
way to express that gift.
But if they learn anything from the class,
it's not be an entrepreneur
like these people.
If entrepreneurship happens
to be your calling, great,
here's what great people do, but figure
out your calling, figure out your gift.
You don't have much time.
Don't live someone else's life.
Don't live by somebody else's thinking,
live your gift and
actualize it to the fullest.
How do people who say hear that?
And I'm sure you go into a much more
detailed in the class, there's 13,
13 lectures. But for those
people listening, if they
wanted a place to start,
just to get a toe hold and they
say, God, I want to do that.
I just don't know what my gift is.
What would you say to them?
Like what are the sort of
whispers through the ether?
They should pay attention to her.
Any indication.
I'd say spend time with
awesome people and, uh,
work on things with them
and, uh, you'll find it.
But most people,
most people fail to find their gift,
not because they can't find it,
it's because they're too busy worrying
about what other people think.
And like one of the things that I find,
uh,
so like one of the things I
find inspiring is that, um, I,
I wrote this post one time and
I was surprised that, so a,
I call it finding billion dollar secrets.
And the point that I was trying to make
was that billion dollar secrets are
everywhere. It's just that people aren't
looking to pick them up off the ground.
They're looking at each other,
they're looking at status,
they're looking at, hey,
when I was in high school,
I got rewarded for giving the teacher
the answer to the questions the way they
wanted it,
and then I went to the right college
and got the right to graduate degree and
got the right job at the right company
and live in the right neighborhood and
had the right designer kids and send them
to the right designer schools and was
in the right country. Clubs drive
my right designer car and they get,
they get focused on,
you know Peter Teal would probably call
this magnetic behavior, right? This,
this idea of people's desires
being defined by the people
around them and what's
going to make a good impression
on the people around them.
The best entrepreneurs I know,
they're just like, screw all that.
I know why I'm here in this world,
that secret on the ground.
That's my gift on picking it up. I'm
doing this and, and like that to me,
that's the thing I tell my 20 year
old self, my 15 year old self,
my kids is like, figure
out your gift, your gift.
It's not, it's not the world's
opinion of your gift. It is yours.
It belongs to you and figure out the
gift that belongs to you and express your
gratitude for the time you
have by offering that gift.
I love it.
[inaudible] you
guys can see why I've bugged Mike so
much over the years. The questions,
speaking of questions. Sure. Boy.
Wow. This must be, this is like the
Willy Wonka golden ticket of questions.
Thanks. Oh Wow. Look at this. Oh,
look at that road question givers.
All right.
I hope a lot of these,
I had no idea it was a lot more
from your answers. I think.
I know this is like the Improv jazz
of question receiving. All right,
so I'll, I'll start with the, uh,
start with the first one and then we'll
just kind of bounced between these.
So the Oh God, a two
part always, which by the
way means two questions. Where would
you have moved besides Austin? Uh,
there are a few places I looked,
I looked at, I love Austin.
I've wanted to move there
since I graduated from
school and she didn't get the
job at trilogy software. Funny
Story, founder of trilogy.
It was my roommate in college, so I
could have helped you looked, you know,
I didn't know what to do. I was, I was,
I was, I was lost a babe in the woods.
So Boulder, Colorado. I'm
a huge fan of boulder.
I also looked at BC.
I really like British Columbia
and areas up in Canada.
Uh, sorry, Americans.
Thank you. Uh, and uh,
there were many different
places that I considered,
but Austin has this gravitational
pull for me, so I ended up there.
What changed my mind or on the
significance of fiction versus nonfiction?
Really it was because I had onset
insomnia and I did not want to turn on my
problem solving apparatus by reading
business books and so on before bed.
And I found that fantasy dune Ender's
game stranger in a strange land,
uh, the name of the wind. Read that,
but be prepared to wait like 17
years for the last and the trilogy.
You ever read that Crowd Count of Monte
Cristo? You don't haven't, oh my gosh.
Speaking of a book about grudges,
what,
since we're on books,
what books do you most
recommend or gifted the other
people? Hmm. Gosh, uh,
lately I've liked, um,
there's a,
there's a woman named Bronnie ware called,
she wrote a book called the top five
regrets of the dying and she was a hospice
nurse who would spend time with people
in the last 90 days of their life.
And um,
she would,
she would learn like what their regrets
were or sometimes she'd learned what
their happiness was. So, um,
there was an example of this woman
who was from super rich family and uh,
she decided to marry an
artist in the family.
Ex communicated her and
she's like 32 years old,
she gets cancer and she dies and she
hasn't heard from her family and years.
And, uh, her mom comes to her at the end
and says, uh, you know, to be honest,
I was just jealous.
You were living life on your own terms
and I've got all these obligations,
I don't even like my life that much.
And I was just kind of pissed off that
you could go marry some artists and be
this happy.
And I realize like how wrong I was.
But this woman who's Diane says,
I have no regrets.
I got to be with the person
that I wanted to be with.
And like I would've loved
to have lived longer,
but nobody knows how much
time they're going to have.
At least I got to have the time that I
got the way I wanted to have it the best
I knew how.
And,
and then they would have another
person who the opposite was true.
They would be dying and they'd say,
promise me brawny that you will not
live life according to other people's
thinking.
Cause I live my whole life trying to
please other people and if I could have it
over again, I wouldn't
do that. And so she,
she does a great job of like having the
example of the person who did it well
with no regrets and the person who's
like, fuck right, I'm dead now.
And like I could do it over
again, I'd do it different.
And so, so, um, and, and it's,
it's motivating to say, gosh, you know,
how am I measuring up against
those five things? And so,
so I like that book because it kind of
takes people out of the here and now and
kind of forces you to confront
a broader set of issues.
Yeah, I think that for me in the last
few years, I had a lot of death, uh,
friends pass away in the
last two years or so,
and including Terry Laughlin,
rest in peace who is in this
book and just a few weeks ago.
And I found it really in an odd way,
reaffirming to familiarize myself
with death and grief and grieving,
uh, and in, in almost a preemptive
way. I mean, one of my favorite people,
I'm sure you've spent time with Matt
Mullenweg, incredible entrepreneur,
but first and foremost,
just a beautiful human being.
And he lost his father
in a very unexpected way.
And he recommended on grief and
grieving to me. And I think it's,
I think it's a very useful exercise to
familiarize yourself with the details of
death and people passing.
And I learned a lot of this from Julie
who is my love of my life and puts up
with me and uh,
you know,
she's helped all these people who
have had cancer. And so as a result,
she ends up seeing a lot of people pass.
And you know,
I think more than anybody, she
taught me that in the last, um,
the last bit of time you have
all the shit falls away, right?
All the expectations,
all the external stuff.
And so you just hope that when that,
when that time comes, you're like,
I did the best I could, you know,
do it the way I could. And so, um,
that's, uh, that's why I
find that that book helpful.
It's not cause I'm preoccupied with dying.
I hope I live a long time,
but it's like when the time comes,
I want to say I did it my way.
I did the best I could.
I honored the gift.
That's a good book.
And there's business books too, but
oh, we'll do that. So I think that's a
good place to, to move. Ours is
everybody. Cool life. You have to leave.
You have to leave at people
call with going a little longer
fun. I hope you guys all
right. So here we go. Uh,
this is the left turn from
when we were talking about,
but I'm curious to hear your answer.
What emerging technologies or theoretical
technology that can really go wide,
uh, do you believe are most promising
for anti authoritarian disruption?
How that's a leading question is similar
to how bitcoin disrupts government
control of money. Maybe. Uh, I'm very
interested in crypto and blockchain.
You mentioned blockchain earlier,
so I'm going to too bad we don't have an
involved here. Yeah, that'd be awesome.
But I would be curious to,
to hear first your thoughts,
general thoughts on crypto and
blockchain and then any other emerging
technologies that you think are promising
for anti-authority disruption. Okay.
So, um, uh, I hope this isn't a
shaggy dog answer. Uh, but, uh,
I don't even know what that is, but the
stories a really long story, your friends.
But um, so, so for better or worse,
I'm a little bit of a history
buff when it comes to business.
And so I took this class when I was in
business school and only Harvard business
school would have a class called the
coming of managerial capitalism. And uh,
but it was a fascinating class because
he named roles like for example,
like in the year 1820,
there weren't any companies in America
with more than a hundred employees,
you know, cause you had people
trading, selling muskets or for,
or like if you are a
really big monster company,
you were like a spinning loom and
Waltham, Massachusetts, uh, and,
and spinning yarn and fabric.
Well then the railroad and
the steam engine come out
and that changes everything.
So like what people don't realize about
people like John Rockefeller and JP
Morgan and Andrew Carnegie,
like,
imagine you're doing standard oil
and you want to compete with a guy in
Pennsylvania on oil prices.
You don't just whip out your cell phone
and call the branch manager and say, Hey,
lower the prices. Run this guy out of
business. I mean, there's no accounting,
there's no org charts,
there's no salary managers.
We don't even have the telegraph
yet. We don't have shit. Right?
And like Rockefeller is building
the company against that backdrop.
And then you know, JP Morgan's like, well,
there's nobody who has enough money
to own a transcontinental railroad,
so maybe I should do this thing where
you create these fractional units of
ownership of a company.
We'll call it stock. You're,
you're some guy who sells your
blacksmith and 1820 and somebody says,
do you want buy stock in a railroad?
You're like,
what good does that do me stock in
some random company. It doesn't exist.
Why would I want that?
And so like,
but what happened was the
modern corporation emerged
and it drove the standard
of living of humanity 13 fold from the
year 1820 to 2000 the richest man in
American 1870 was Cornelius Vanderbilt.
He didn't have flushing toilets.
He didn't have running water.
He didn't have electricity.
You can have all those three
things now and be defined as poor.
And so I look at it and I'm like, people
say capitalism is screwed up. I'm like,
what are you talking about? Like
I'm like, it's a freaking miracle.
It's like it in 1800 you had to work
one hour to get six minutes of reading
light.
Today you work one hour,
you get 300 days of reading
light. It's a miracle. And,
and you know,
there's a lot of stuff that is wrong with
how people are practicing capitalism,
but free trade and voluntary,
you know, I have this to offer,
you have that to offer. We get to
trade without somebody interference.
That's not the problem. That's
not the problem we have. Well,
what I think is happening today,
and this is where blockchain gets in.
I'm hearing a little Texas,
sorry for this share. No, no. Uh,
I believe that that blockchain
and things like it and, and, uh,
Moore's law Metcalf's law
or the fundamental animating
forces of what I like to
call network capitalism.
And I believe that someday
value is going to be created,
not by creating a large company. We have
a lot of employees that work for you,
uh, and produce a lot
of stuff, but it's dead.
It's going to be the people who create
and curate software to find networks. And,
um, I think that Tesla is a software
network defined car company.
And I think that apple was a software
network defined phone company.
Nokia thought they sell
widgets. Apple thought, no,
we sell sell software to find phone.
The bet between Tesla and GM has nothing
to do with WHO's selling more cars.
It said we'll Tesla figure
out manufacturing faster
than GM figures out how to
be a software to find network capitalist
company. Right? So, so like, okay,
now back to blockchain. Uh, there's a,
there's a book called like a lot called
the wealth of networks by Yo. Hi Bankler.
I read it about 10 years ago and
it influenced my investing a lot.
And one of the things that that Bankler
talked about was we're going to move
from the tragedy of the Commons
to the wealth of the Commons.
And the examples he used back then,
he had dig in the book actually.
And he had examples of user generated
content, open source software.
Well what if just like the stock market
was a new way to practice capitalism for
the modern corporation animated
by the railroad, the steam engine,
that is a new way to create abundance
because you couldn't have had a national
railroad unless you had a stock
market. You couldn't have said, hey,
who has enough money to build a railroad?
There was no one person who did.
And so now I believe that crypto has
the opportunity create the wealth of the
Commons.
And um,
rather than a centrally organized
equity capital structure,
you have a set of people who contribute
to a project on their own volition.
And if the other people,
their peers in the community judge their
value as compelling, they get rewarded.
So it's, it's kind of like the
wealth of the Commons, but like,
I find it easier to think about
Crypto, not through the lens of, Oh,
sorry,
you're gonna Invest in Crypto company.
How many shares are you going to own?
That's wrong.
That's like asking how many dollars or
am I going to own in the transcontinental
railroad? No stock units or a new
thing. Yeah, it's a different unit.
Crypto tokens are a new thing.
They are a new way to create wealth.
They are a new way to leverage the
wealth of networks rather than vertically
integrated top down owned companies.
And so like I just believe that
a hundred years from now, uh,
tokens or something like them will be
one of many ways that a enterprise and
capitalists can create abundance in the
world and the more ways we can create
abundance of better,
does that obliterate ventral cap venture
capital as we know it or does it just
reconfigure it so that you guys are
investing in the pickaxes? Yeah,
so like I don't really,
it's funny,
so like I'm friends with Vinny Lingham
who did civic and the first time we met
he's like, Hey, I see
owners make you irrelevant,
but I'm happy to give you courtesy of
my time. And I'm like, Vinny, like,
look, I'm just not afraid of
what's going to be done to me.
The question I asked today is,
what would JP Morgan do if he's alive?
JP Morgan wouldn't be like, oh, how am I
going to get disrupted? Oji He'd be like,
how can I play off fence with crypto and
how can I create new businesses rather
than, you know, like Elvis didn't
say I'm going to disrupt jazz, right?
He wanted to create rock and roll. And
like when I look about Crypto, I'm like,
what would Elvis think?
What would JP Morgan think?
I think disruption in tech startups
kind of bullshit. None of the,
none of the tech startups I've invested
in had people who said, you know,
Logan and John didn't say death
to taxis, right? They were like,
ride sharing is going to be awesome.
It's going to bring people together
and make things better. And um,
disruption happens after
you win almost by accident.
And it doesn't happen because
you try to defeat taxis.
It happens because you
transcend taxis and, and like,
so like whenever people say, I'm going
to disrupt something, I'm like, well,
you're not a real entrepreneur because
entrepreneurship comes from love and
creation, not from anger and disruption.
And what am I going to attack?
And so like I don't like,
I'm not going to get
disrupted by crypto any
more than the next guy will.
So just Jamie diamond might,
by the way, I'd be happy to debate
him anytime and anywhere. Ooh, like
this. This is the rumble in
the jungle. Jamie diamond.
I can't wait for this to happen.
So just so nobody gets fired.
I did get the wrap up.
Smiley face sign,
but I'm going to temporarily ignore that.
I apologize.
Just so that everybody knows someone
who's done their duty and I'm going to
continue for a few more
questions and then we'll wrap up.
I appreciate everyone okay with that.
Cool.
Because I'm having fun with my Bud Mike.
Uh Oh my God.
All these questions.
I wonder if this is the same person,
what nascent tech could most disempowered
the state where you see tech potential
for removing government control over the
individual? Holy Shit. We got a bunch of,
so the way,
this is one of the reasons I liked the
wealth of networks is that the wealth and
networks potentially creates the opening
to reestablish the idea of trade is a
voluntary activity between people.
And the government's role is not to own
everything or legislate everything or
give her buddy handouts or
free Scooby snacks. It's too,
it is to protect the rights of people.
That's why I believe valid role of
governments protect the rights of people.
And what we've allowed our government
to do is to have unsound practices with
how they create, how they treat
money, right? So the Fed is,
and with the money supply and
it's hurting honest people,
but if we want to explore that we can,
but like the Fed jacking with the money
supply is picking the pockets of the
middle class and it is
a right. And um, and,
and like the crypto has the opportunity
to say money should have a price just
like everything else. And just like we
need to separate politics and religion.
We need to separate
politics and economics.
Whoa.
Oh my God. We'd get on so many
Rad. No, no, no. It's great.
Yeah,
man. I can't wait for this rumble
in the jungle. Jimmy diamond.
It's going to be great. I don't want
front row tickets. All right. Uh,
what were the traits that you had
early on that made you successful?
Yeah,
I'll just leave it at that.
That's from Jignesh and I'll leave the
last name out just so I don't have to get
permission for keeping you on the podcast.
Um,
I just think that, uh, I
was lucky that, um, uh,
I was born with parents who were just
really good to me and inspired me in ways
that were surprising that
I didn't understand at the
time. Like when I was, uh,
we're not,
when I was in third grade,
my dad bought me this book called how
it works, illustrated for my birthday.
It was all these diagrams and how product,
you know, how it is dishwasher work,
how does it get this book? It's
a great, it's a great book.
And he writes in the front, it's like, um,
I know is a little bit advanced
for third grader, but uh, you know,
it'll make you think differently
about life and uh, you know,
someday you're going to invent things
are going to be in a book like this.
Yup.
What is it like, who has parrots like
that? Like I didn't decide that. Yeah.
Just like, just like, uh, you're,
you know, when you're a parent,
your kids are you nothing.
It doesn't mean you can't be grateful
when you get lucky and have good ones.
Yeah. Here, here.
Yeah. I'm curious about
that too. Ah, you know, I,
I also, I think in a lot of
ways won the parent lottery.
I wish I could give a
better answer, but it, well,
the one thing that my parents did,
they were there a few things my parents
did that I think were very helpful in
retrospect.
Now it's all
kind of post hoc analysis,
right? So who knows?
But I would say number one, I, you
know, I wasn't, it's not like we,
we didn't have a flushing
toilet and electricity's,
it's not like my parents
would go your board,
but we didn't have her neos
Vanderbilt. Yeah. But we didn't have,
we didn't have a lot of extra
cash floating around, uh,
parents that are made more than 50 grand
or so a year combined. And, um, anyway,
the point was two things.
Number one is they said, no,
you can't have the new bike,
can't do it, can't do this.
But they said this is, I mean,
maybe it was by necessity,
not by engineering,
but they said the one thing,
we have budget for his books.
So if you really want a book,
like we'll figure it out.
And so we used to go to the remainder
table in this bookstore or our local
hometown and pick books. And I remember
to this day, some of those books,
just like you do, fishes of the
world was when I wanted to be,
become a marine biologist for 10 plus
years because of this book and bought it
for whatever,
70% off.
And I carried it with me to school every
day because that's the playground for
me. I was a runner. I was a
really small kid, born premature.
He got the shit kicked out of me
like weekly until sixth grade.
So I would stay close to
the teacher with this book.
And I remember, I don't,
I've never talked about this.
Remember this one teacher
substitute teacher,
not my real teachers cause they knew me,
but the substitute teacher said to
my mom, you know, you shouldn't have,
you shouldn't let him bring that book
to school. He's going to destroy it.
And my mom was like, what are you talking
about? Like it's like destroy that book.
Like it's those important book he has.
And uh,
they were very good at
training us to want books.
So that was a key. And
then second was, uh,
my parents and my mom particularly,
we're really good at just exposing
me to a lot of stuff. Yup.
And it was free stuff.
It's like, all right,
we're going to take a trip to
the aquarium when it's free.
We're going to go to the beach and
we're going to collect black sand with a
magnet.
And I'll try to explain it back to Tim is,
and my mom through so much against the
wall and every once in a while something
would stick and then she would just
put everything behind it. Yeah.
Yeah. Me Too. Like I read
some book and I said, well,
the best example of this dinosaur bones
is in the museum of natural history in
Washington DC. And my mom would
say, well, we live in Princeton,
New Jersey at the time. And, uh, there's
a museum of natural history in New York.
And I'm like, but that's not where the
biggest one is. And that's where like,
sure enough,
we'd be going to Washington DC to see
the biggest and like Carolyn Maples,
like had like,
if I was interested in dinosaurs and
that's where I wanted to see the biggest
dinosaur.
Like by Golly,
we were going to museum of
natural history in Washington DC.
And maybe while we're at it,
we'll go to Gettysburg and learn something
about the civil war. But it was uh, uh,
one other thing that I think is good
and then onto the next thing. But, um,
my dad also told me don't have heroes.
And I think what he meant by that was
that hero worship is a form of not
thinking for yourself
because heroes first of all,
a lot of times they're kind of a story
and you don't really know what they're
really like and what really happened
and why they decided what they did.
But the other thing is defining
yourself relative to somebody else's
accomplishment or how somebody else
acts causes you to not spend the time to
discover how you can be your best self.
And so like,
it's okay to respect the way somebody
thinks or it's okay to respect a talent
that somebody has it you could learn from.
But that's different from saying,
oh my gosh,
Bill Gates is awesome.
I want to be like Bill Gates because
Bill Gates is awesome, right?
He's awesome at being bill gates.
But you need to be awesome at being you.
And like having a hero can cause
you to drift away from that.
So my dad was always very, whenever
somebody famous on TV, you know,
wrong, Reagan was president
when I was young, he'd be like,
be very careful not to have heroes. You
don't know their whole story. He's like,
he may be great person, but don't have
it. Don't have that person as a hero.
Figure out what you admire that
they do and try to understand that.
But don't, don't say, I want to be like
that person ever. It's a good guideline.
Yeah. That's pretty good. That's pretty
good. I don't know how I figured that out.
This is a question from anonymous.
Very nice handwriting. Um,
what would you put on a billboard?
Could be,
I don't know if you answered
it in the books. I did. He
did. So let's, let's hear.
It could be that or it could be something
else, but how would you answer that?
What would you put on the billboard
that got out to millions or billions of
people? Uh, like, um, there's two things.
One would be integrity is the only
path where you'll never get lost.
And that's the one that,
that I put your book.
And then the other one would
be think for yourself always.
And I'm thinking for yourself
doesn't mean don't listen,
but it means be willing to have first
principles and you are right or wrong,
not because of how powerful the
person is who challenges you.
You are right or wrong based on whether
the content of your ideas and first
principles as right or wrong.
And you should,
you should seek out people who challenge
your first principles like goal because
they'll make you better,
but you shouldn't, you know,
and that's like ego is about who's
right and truth is about what's right.
And if you become an authentic
truth seeker in life, uh,
to me that's kind of what it means.
Did like think for yourself? Yeah,
it's for you. I'm not nurse. I'm not going
to follow that up. Y'all come on guys.
No,
everybody wants to know.
You're signing one record player that
says the same thing over and over again.
All right, so I would say I'm going to
give a new answer, actually have two.
So the first would be,
and this is advice I got really early on
that has stuck with me for decades now,
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most and drew of
Dropbox.
Many of the people would give similar
advice and I think it's just so important
emotionally,
financially,
psychologically it's very important that
you choose the people you spend time
with. It doesn't have to be in person, it
can be via podcast, it can be via books,
they don't have to be alive.
It could be Ben Franklin and I've learned
so much from Richard Fiman and Ben
Franklin for instances.
Just two examples.
And,
and can I just double down on that because
like it doesn't even have to be five
people that will help you succeed in
your career. So like, like Julie, right.
I was talking about earlier, uh, one of,
one of the companies that we invested in,
the founder's son was 10 years old,
got a brain tumor and so he has to
be operated on in San Francisco.
And uh,
Julie calls me and says,
when are you going to get here? It was
like a few days later and I'm like, uh,
sorry. Am I supposed to, I'm
in this meeting. I'm like,
where are you? She's like,
I'm here at the hospital.
Who goes about to be operated on?
Where are you? And I realize
like she never said, hey,
let's meet at the hospital.
But like what I realized
from her was that she's like,
what else are you doing that's more
important than being here right now? Like,
why did I have to tell you that?
And she wasn't being judgmental about
it was just to her, it was just obvious.
And so like,
part of it is not just five awesome
business people or five fortune 500
whatever. It's, to me,
it's more like five people who in their
own way make you appreciate the gift of
life in a more deep way so
that you practice it better.
And like where you say,
wow,
that person changed my point of
view about how to use my time.
How do you use your life?
Yeah.
We're going to wrap up in a minute folks.
Uh,
I said I would give something new.
I've given you're the average of the five
people you associate with most a lot.
So I'll give you another one
to keep interrupting you,
which is relatively recent
discovery for me, which is
if you want to succeed
in any holistic capacity,
if you want to love the people you care
for fully and have them feel that you
cannot do it.
If you merely tolerate yourself,
you cannot do it. If on some level you
lose yourself or aspects of yourself,
and I spent,
I mean,
I've spent decades of my life like
barely at best tolerating myself.
I had some bad things happen to me.
I as a consequence,
decided to just hone myself into an
instrument of competition. That was it,
and I found validation and a purpose in
that and being number one and the any
joy I felt, it was really from
observing other people experiencing joy.
It wasn't intrinsic to me
and I'm
forgiving yourself. We're loving
yourself as not a nice to have.
It is a must have.
Even if you're doing it just for other
people and the people you want to express
your love to most fully you. You need to
solve that and there are ways to do it.
There are ways to do it.
That's the good news.
So I would just say whether it's a book
like Tara Brocks, radical acceptance,
terrible title,
a great book or Paul's Book,
love yourself like your life depends on
it. Yeah. Call Robert [inaudible] book.
Also exceptional of that is I think the
root cause of so many things that we can
perceive is 30 or 40 or 50
different problems to solve.
And in fact they're just one or two things
that happened to you that you need to
unpack. Yep. 10 with, can you double click
on that for a second? Cause I don't like,
I think it's like people
will sometimes say, Hey,
you should love yourself and they'll
will dumb down that they won't understand
the subtlety like of what you just said.
And I think that's important. Yeah.
So the, the, the subtlety,
if we were to drill down,
I would say that, uh, and this
is borrowing from someone,
actually it's in the conclusion of Trevor
mentors it because it's that important
to me.
Um,
Jim Loehr or lair who's a performance
coach has worked with a lot of incredible
athletes and he, l, O, e, h, r,
fascinating guy and his book,
a mental toughness training
for sports. Here you go.
Uh, Mari more really changed
my life. Sure. You're good
in high school. Don't worry.
I know I'm getting them.
I'm getting the stink eye.
I'll make it up to everybody.
Uh, tell the whole story, Tim.
So,
uh,
the gym expressed to me when I met with
him to learn how to play tennis for the
first time, just in the last year, which
had always wanted to do my whole life.
He said a in effect,
you know,
the most important voice we ever hear in
our lives is the voice that no one else
hears.
It's the voice in our own heads.
And for my entire life, I
would really, my entire life,
it's been the most merciless,
brutal coach or wish on your worst day.
Like,
raise your hand if you said something
to yourself negative in your own mind
today. Yeah. Right.
And you can create,
even if externally you have all of
the material trappings or rewards of a
financially successful career.
If you have the nuclear family
that everyone has dreamed
of and painted a Norman
Rockwell paintings, if that inner
voice is just a demon on your back,
you will not find the piece that
you want and nothing you buy,
nothing you achieve will provide that.
There are just things you need to unpack
so that that voice becomes a different
voice. It is it fair to him
to say that part of love is a,
like you can love your
country without thinking.
It's perfect and you can love your kids
without thinking they're perfect and
part of like loving yourself is like
saying, that doesn't mean I'm perfect.
I'm not going to be
jingoistic about myself.
It's more about I'm going to hold myself
and hire enough regard that I'm going
to do the best I can with the day that
I have and I'm going to forgive myself
when I screw up, honestly.
Yeah, that's a big part of it.
And also for people who were looking
for maybe a tactical recommendation.
One thing I found very helpful,
and I do want to take too
much time to go into it,
but something called Metta Emmy TTA
meditation or loving kindness meditation.
I went through meditation
retreat recently,
which was very difficult for
me and I was practicing this.
Just Google it. You'll find plenty, uh,
to convey in my meditation love and
wishes for happiness to many different
people who had helped
me throughout my life.
And I remember one of the teachers
at the retreat said the very end,
I was about to walk out the door
and she said, wait a second,
have you done any loving kindness
to earlier versions of yourself who
experienced a lot of pain, who
maybe felt unsafe? And I was like,
didn't even occur to me to do that.
I would encourage everybody
here to accept Laura that,
and I know we're running out of time.
So Mike,
I have one more question and then
I'll have some closing thoughts.
This is the tradition at the forum to ask,
what is your 62nd idea
to change the world? Uh,
pressure.
Okay.
Think for yourself and be kind to yourself
in your own mind because 90% of the
unkindness that happens in the world
is actually people being unkind to
themselves. And if you're going to be,
if you set out to make the world better,
being kind to yourself in your own mind
is probably the most straight forward,
high return UC or time possible.
Cheers to that.
[inaudible] Mike,
I just want to say I that
it's been such a joy and a privilege to
know you for as long as I have and uh,
I really hope to spend more time with you.
I mean,
we've spent a lot of time together,
but I'd like to spend more time and I
really truly believe in part of the reason
I wanted to bring you
out on stage tonight.
You're one of the most genuine unentitled
positive people who want to also impart
the gift of positivity to the world I've
ever met. So I just want to
thank you for that. Alright,
well it's been fun to see you
do so well. Well, you too man.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Mike Naples.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week. That could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com I love workflows.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my go to platform for
blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for
everything every day. My site,
tim.blog is built on it. The
website's for books, tools of titans,
tribe of mentors, all in wordpress.com
and the founder Matt Mullenweg.
One of my close friends has
appeared on the show many times.
Just search that Mall Tequila
Ferris for quite an exciting,
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site, or both,
you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be
in good company. It's used
by the New Yorker, Jay Z,
Beyonce, five 38 tech
crunch, Ted CNN time,
just to name a handful,
and
one
of my
friends@googleshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers
the best out of the box SEO imaginable,
but,
and it's one of the many reasons that
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you
through the entire experience,
the hundreds of designs and
templates that you can use,
and it's easy to get started. There's no
need to worry about security upgrades,
boosting any of that they have for
24 seven support and they're very,
very responsive.
He's questions that you're right back
to you and this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least
amount of headache and friction.
So if you're building a website,
period,
when my friends come to
me and ask what I used,
what I recommend that you use the
answer is wordpress.com to check it out.
Do you want to get started today?
Learn more with a 15%
discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim
create your website and find the plan's
right for you to learn more.
Take a look.
wordpress.com four slash 10
15% off a brand new website.
Check it out. This episode is
brought to you by convert kit.
My go to email service provider.
I use them for everything.
If you've ever wondered how
professional bloggers, podcasters,
youtubers and so on can build a platform
they control and get the word out about
their best content. Email is still the
answer I, it's all social, social, social,
but one algorithm change and oops,
bait and switch.
Now you only reach 10% of your audience.
That is why I've doubled
and tripled down on email.
After reviewing many different
email service providers,
I ended up selecting convert
kit for like five bullet Friday,
which goes out to about a million people
now because convert kit delivers on
what matters most to me,
at least. Easy use systems,
split testing and resending
technology, both very, very important.
High rates of deliverability and
great hands on customer service.
So whether you run a
business or simply have,
say a serious blog convert kit has
integrations with more than 70 different
services just about anything you might
need including hosting sites like
wordpress, ecommerce platforms
like Shopify and lead capture,
technology of bounce exchange
for sumo and many more.
They also offer a visual
automation builder that makes
it really easy to deliver
the right content to the right people in
your audience, just what they want it.
If you want to segment in different ways,
which a lot of people do,
convert kit offers, plans that
adjusted the size of your business,
so it's a good option whether you have
a thousand people or 1 million on your
list and certainly I am
planning on growing and
growing and growing and I don't
like switching email service providers,
so I thought very carefully about
this before. It's like check it out.
Take a look at convertkit.com/tim
that's convergent,
Con v e r t k,
I t.com forward slash Tim and you
can get your first month for free.
Kick the tires,
test it out that way and give it a shot.
Make sure that it works for you, your
business and all of that. Goodness.
If you're like me, I hope you'll
find that they get the job done.
That's certainly been my experience.
It's checking out again.
That's convert kit.com forward slash Tim
for a free month of, you know, surfaces.